-Our first guest tonight
is a very funny actress
you know from movies
such as "The Other Woman,"
"This is 40," and "Blockers."
She's currently starring
in "The Bubble,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Leslie Mann,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi!
-Hi!
-So lovely to see you!
-Yeah, it's been a long time.
-it has been a long time.
It is lovely
having you here in person.
And I think, since the last time
I've seen you,
you are now officially,
the term is,
you are an empty-nester.
-I know.
-Yeah.
-I am.
-Both girls are
out of the house.
-Yes, they are.
I have Iris, who's 19,
and she's now in college,
and then Maude, who is 24.
Is she 25? No, she's --
[ Laughter ]
She's 24?
-We'll correct it in post.
-I think.
[ Laughter ]
And, um, yeah, I'm --
you know, I got pregnant --
So, yeah, she's 25.
[ Laughter ]
So, I got --
I got pregnant 25 years ago,
and I basically have only
thought about them...
-Yeah.
-...and their interests
and their health and wellbeing,
and that's it.
And haven't thought about myself
in 25 years.
And now that they want nothing
to do with me, I'm like...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I don't know what -- who I am.
-Yeah, you maybe are a little --
you're, like, addicted to them,
and now you have to wean
yourself off, there, every day.
-I think so, yeah.
I mean, I'm, like, lost.
And people say, like,
"Do you have hobbies?
Or what are your interests?"
And I don't have any.
[ Laughter ]
I know what Iris
is interested in
and what my Maude
is interested in,
but i don't know.
-Yeah.
-And, okay, so, I -- I --
I've been talking
to a lot of people about this.
-Trying to get advice.
-Yeah, yeah, like,
"What do I do
about this problem?"
And a lot of people are
telling me to try ayahuasca...
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-...which is like, apparently,
you take ayahuasca,
which is like an amino acid.
-Okay.
-And, um, you meet God.
-Yeah.
-And God tells you
what your path should be.
-Yes, it's like a supplement,
like a vitamin supplement.
You get at it, like, GNC.
[ Laughter ]
No, but I've heard --
First of all,
I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and say you're getting
a lot of advice
from parents
who live in Los Angeles.
[ Laughter ]
-I think I have.
-I think this is very much
empty-nester advice
from Hollywood.
-i know, I know.
-'Cause it seems like
what I've heard about ayahuasca,
not having done it --
-You haven't done it?
-No, I haven't done it.
No interest, no interest.
-Really?
-Absolutely not.
-Okay.
-First of all,
it sounds very intense, right?
It's like sweat-lodgey and --
-Yeah, and vomiting.
-Yeah, like
a 12- to 24-hour trip.
Also, by the way,
I love His work.
I don't want to meet God.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Like, I don't want to --
Also, I don't want to talk to
anybody who thinks they met him.
-Right, I know.
-Know what I mean?
-Yes!
-Yeah!
-And what if he tells you,
like, do something
that you really
don't want to do?
Like, "Your path is this thing."
-Have you met people
who, like, lives are now taking,
like, a sharp right turn because
that they did ayahuasca?
Now they're like, "Yeah,"
so now..."?
-No.
-"Now I'm wearing these shirts."
-No, those people don't seem...
-Yeah.
I think there's a lot of people
who are like, "I went,
and God said,
'You're doing great.'"
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a lot of people
who are, like, already
feeling pretty good about
how they're doing, yeah.
So don't do that.
-Don't do ayahuasca, okay?
-But also, like, I imagine,
as a mom,
you are, you know, a loving mom.
You keep an eye on your kids.
Did you have to, like,
at some point,
let go of that and let them...
Are you letting them
live their own lives?
Are you, like, not keeping tabs
on them
in the way you did
when they were in the house?
-Um, I gee --
I-I kind of...
Well, they...
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Since they moved out,
they stopped letting me
follow them on Find My Friends,
which is a tracking app.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But what they don't know is
that, um...
And we're not gonna tell them.
-No, of course not.
[ Laughter ]
-...is that their Uber accounts
are connected to my credit card,
so every time
they go somewhere...
-Wow.
-...it alerts me.
And which sounds really,
you know...
It's -- I know.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But, um, okay, so, I, you know,
them being out of the house,
I get nervous
and I want to make sure that
they're home safe at night.
And when I get the alert
that they're, like,
off to the bar or something,
I, um, you know, can't sleep.
And so I sometimes
will text them, "Go home."
And -- And they're like...
[ Laughter ]
Like, "How does she know
I'm not at home?"
And they think I'm psychic.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
At least that --
At least they're
getting something from you
in this, sort of,
because at least you're paying
for their Ubers, right?
-Right, yeah.
-You are being, like,
sort of a big-brother character
in their lives,
but at least, you know,
there's a little --
there's a little quid pro quo.
They're getting free rides.
-Free rides, yeah.
-And now, Maude,
who was here recently,
and it was so lovely
talking to her,
she is in "Euphoria,"
which is a show
that a lot of parents --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
This is a show
that panics parents,
because I think
a lot of parents watch that.
And, you know, my kids
are younger than yours,
and when I see "Euphoria,"
I'm like, "Oh, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
I don't think you're ever
gonna go to school now."
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
-But you've had the benefit,
obviously,
not only do you know Maude
but you've gotten to meet
some of the other people
in the show.
-Yes.
-And that is, like, calming,
right?
-Well, it seems like --
I mean, the kids
are doing such crazy things
on the show,
and then they'll come over
to the house
and they're, like, the nicest,
most polite kids
you've ever met,
and so, like, almost boring,
like, just up to nothing.
I think I saw one of them
drink a White Claw once
or something.
Like, just so sweet.
And so they're just
really good actors.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-Have you ever had
a couple glasses of wine
and just been honest and said,
"I thought
you were all gonna be
a lot more fun?"
[ Laughter ]
-I'm the crazy one.
-You're like, "Aah!"
[ Laughter ]
-"Let's go!"
You got to work --
We're gonna show a clip
when we come back,
but you got to work with Iris
on this film, "The Bubble,"
and your husband, Judd Apatow,
directed it.
So, you have three of you
there on set.
Is it -- I mean, that seems like
the best way
for a family
to spend time together,
but do you have boundaries
when you're on set together?
-Well, he has boundaries,
and my daughter has boundaries
with me, obviously.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-There's no, like,
hugging or chitchat.
-This is what she asks of you.
-Yeah.
She's like,
"Keep your distance,"
and you know, keeps it
really professional with me,
which is fine.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, she's --
I mean, I appreciate
what she's doing.
I can't imagine it's like, easy,
but you have to, like, go,
"Well, professionally,
she's probably right."
-Yeah, she wants me to back off,
'cause she wants to do her work.
-You know, I'm lucky enough,
Judd will be here tomorrow,
and I can obviously
ask him this.
Does he feel comfortable
directing her?
I mean...
-I think that he is
a little bit, um,
you know --
he's very --
that's his one area to be, like,
bossy and controlling with us,
because they rule him at home.
-Oh, right.
-So, he's at work.
He gets a little, you know --
he gets to, like, you know,
speak up.
-Oh, that's nice.
So it's cathartic for him,
I Imagine,
growing up in
a house full of women.
For him to finally be able to,
like, say "Cut"
when you're talking
must be so nice.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
-I have more questions
about "The Bubble."
We'll be right back
with more from Leslie Mann.